Okay David, what did you have for
the first sentence?
>> So for the first sentence, I created
the predicates lays eggs, feathers, and
reptile, and
said if the animal lays eggs and
the animal does not have feathers
that implies the animal is a reptile.
For the second one,
I said if the animal has feathers or
the animal has talons that implies
that the animal is a bird.
So animal feathers or
talons, feathers or talons.
For the third,
which is a longer one, I said,
if the the animal lays eggs and the
animal has a beak and the animal flies,
all three of these all in a chain,
that implies the animal is a duck.
And similar for the fourth one, we have
three predicates on the left side.
If the animal lays eggs,
the animal has a beak, and
the animal does not fly,
then the animal is a Platypus.
This guy shows us why a platypus is
such a strange animal because we need to
make a lot of caveats in order to
find what a platypus really is.
>> Good David, that looks right to me.
So to wrap this part up, let us note
that when we defined what a predicate
was, we set up a predicate like
Flies can map into true or false.
Well okay,
a predicate can map into true or false.
What about complicated sentences like
this, which are multiple predicates,
as well as, implications?
How do we find out whether the sentence
as a whole maps into true or false?
That's what we're going to look at next.
We're looking at truth tables.